there's another one you're not going to
get rich renting out your time you must
own equity a piece of a business to gain
your financial freedom that one right
there is the most important one which is
you basically
in modern life what happens is like the
person who is the best at doing
something in the world will get to do it
for the entire world through a
combination of leverage and distribution
accountability and specific knowledge
with all of which i talk about in the
tweet storm
if you're the best in the world of doing
something like if you're the best
teacher in the world at math you should
be teaching the entire world math if
you're the best podcast interviewer you
should be doing all the top interviews
and their returns will accrue to you
especially in this highly digital world
that where we live in where the cost of
distributing something is very close to
zero
and so
what you kind of want to do is you want
to productize yourself into a business
and then you want to own that business
that is the way to make wealth
a clear example is that tim ferriss
podcast the tim ferriss brand right
you're it's an eponymous brand your name
is on it you're leveraged through this
podcast and through the books that you
write
and through the army of followers that
you have on the various media platforms
and you're taking on big accountability
and their specific knowledge only you
know how to be tim ferriss the learning
machine who can then connect to other
learners and extract value out of them
and share that with the audience so
that's an example of you having
productized yourself but ultimately you
own the tim ferriss business now you can
go lower levels down from that you don't
have to own the entire business you
could be an investor in public equities
or private stocks you could be
a partner in a private business uh you
could be an employee a startup where you
have stock options but if you don't own
a piece of a business you're gonna it's
gonna be extremely hard to get wealthy
it'll be nearly impossible almost not
worth that route so i think that is the
most important foundational tweet i
think where people kind of all
kind of miss the plot the most though
is we have pain avoidance in life we
don't want to face things where it's
clear we've made bad decisions because
one good definition of suffering is that
that's the moment when you see things
that they clearly are and you kind of
don't like what you see like for example
if you if you and your spouse have been
fighting for a long time you know you've
kind of been sweeping under the rug and
you've sort of been suffering along but
you're sweeping on the wrong and then
you get divorced at that moment you can
no longer unsee all the damage that was
in the relationship and what all the
consequences are they're real
uh the same way if you haven't been
taking care of your health but then
suddenly you find out that you've just
fallen off a cliff and something
irreversibly bad has happened the moment
of suffering arrives and you're in pain
because you can no longer unsee this
thing you can no longer avoid it so i
think the same way
the unfortunate part is that a lot of
these principles are written for young
people because you can set yourself on a
certain trajectory in life earlier and
so for example if you went and you got a
you know a phd in a social science and
now i'm basically saying hey learn the
code
you're going to avoid that you're not
going to want to see that because you
have all this sunk cost in the degree so
i think a lot of people don't want to
pick up the new skills that are
necessary or they don't want to for
example physically move or they don't
want to disappoint the people in the
relationships that they already have to
make room for new relationships so
everybody wants to start where they are
nobody wants to go back down the
mountain to find the path going to the
top everybody wants to stay on the path
they're on maybe make a few tweaks and
get to the top or like charlie munger
jokes you know people always ask me like
how do i get to be rich like you except
quicker i don't want to be the old rich
guy i want to be the young rich guy
so i think these are the hard parts the
the the hard parts are not the learning
is the unlearning it's not the climbing
up the mountain it's the going back down
to the bottom of the mountain and
starting over it's the beginner's mind
that every great artist or every great
business person has which is you have to
be willing to start from scratch you
have to be willing to hit reset and go
back to zero because you have to realize
that what you already know and what
you're already doing is actually an
impediment to your full potential and
most people just don't want to
acknowledge that and i'm guilty of that
too that's just human nature i'm not i'm
not faulting anybody for it but it's
just human nature
[Music]
you